long time liberal comic Bill Maher
ripping into his fellow Democrats over
the dangers of woke education
when historians look back at our time
they will not divide us into red and
blue and Republican Democrat they're
like the things that were wrong with us
were wrong with both sides in different
ways I do think they manifest in a more
dangerous way on the right but on the
left there is a rot and it comes from
Academia and I agree and it filters down
am I am I wrong about that that's where
it's all coming from Greg Gutfeld all
right I love listening to that but it's
about 10 years too late again everything
could happen sooner so I'm happy he
finally you know listened to us but I
wrote a book was it 13 years ago called
The Joy of hate which was about this
about the academic we talked about it on
the five every single day how the
anti-speech pro-cancer culture of Campus
was really destructive however we
underestimated the ability to transfer
itself into the real world through it
went through Tech uh Tech platforms like
Facebook and Twitter but then it ended
up in the media and ended up in the HR
of many many large corporations so I
think that like we got it wrong because
we thought that it would die in campus
but he didn't even see it coming Greg
can see the future did you know that yes
it's not good for you it's not good for
you well and I think that so that we've
been on the air this is our 12th year so
it's been going on for like 10 years as
you said 10 years and moms and dads are
not for lower lowering education
standards and teaching this alternative
universe and I I what I'm worried about
is you you mentioned all these other
sectors where it's brought up also in
government look at all the policies that
are being driven now and they have to be
you know they we we people who are
against those win in court but you got
to go through all those steps to get to
that point yeah Academia brought us a
lot of bad stuff communism socialism CRT
Jessica tarloff 16. anything else you
want to apologize for 1619 I
I feel great
um but I like Bill Maher a lot I think
that I wrote a piece calling them like
this class of democrat which I fall into
80 of the time which is disgruntled
Democrats right people who are never
going to vote for the other side right
because they do think that the threat
coming from Republicans is far too great
but they're dissatisfied with having
these kind of like nitty-gritty fights
and this is what Obama was talking about
when he did that podcast a few weeks ago
where he just said you got to let people
B and not make them feel terrible for
everything that they're thinking but the
Academia part because he was talking to
an academic who said at NYU and that's
something that a lot of Democrats are
feeling well not Janine she looks at the
issues she doesn't vote right or left
yeah
and evidence and come to a conclusion
look the thing that disturbs me about
all this is that Harvard and Yale this
weekend decided that they were going to
scrap the LSAT the standardized test
which was I thought a very interesting
move on their part because the LSAT
measures reading comprehension logic and
the ability to work through problems I
get what they're saying that reading
comprehension and a lot of the stuff
that goes into preparing for the LSAT
the law school uh test can be bought
that you can get a tutor to to teach you
how to win at that but at the same time
getting rid of it all I'm not so sure
that they're going to have students who
are going to be able to comply or get
through you know the the the very rigid
uh kind of uh studies that go through
law school I mean it's it's a it's a
bummer so there are good things and bad
things going on in that so our lawyers
are going to be dumber dumber like the
pilots is that possible Greg didn't see
that coming